here's the second one uh turn back to
where you did your starter questions
this morning right the very first thing
i uh i introduced these four seemingly
random
complex numbers two and i named them as
well i called them z1z2z3z4
and then z5 which happened to be the
same as z1 using our language of
real and imaginary components we can
separate out i wonder if you can just do
a little exercise with me
for each of and maybe you want to draw
this little table for yourself too
for each of the numbers and i'm going to
leave z 5 off of this list because it's
clearly the same as the top row
for each of these numbers what's the
real part what's the imaginary part
start me off z1 real component is
five imaginary component is two
next one z2 negative two
and positive five yeah
uh next one down negative five
negative two last one here
uh two and negative five you okay with
that
i want you to stare really hard i'm
inviting you
to kind of be like brown
like that botanist who was staring down
his microscope and he was like
what's going on here is there something
more than what i can see is there's
something invisible underneath this
that's driving
this process these are not just random
numbers right what do you notice what do
you wonder when you have a look at these
does anyone notice any patterns what do
you see
what do you think um
okay so real part of this one imaginary
part of this one
real part imaginary part real part
imaginary part
and you could extend it all the way
around right here comes the real part
and then the imaginary part
good so we're noticing there's this
relationship is there anything else
that you notice every two cycles
it multiplies every two cycles let me
say that again again
every two cycles of multiplying by i
you're essentially multiplying by
minus one that makes sense because each
time we progress we're multiplying by i
so if you do it twice you're multiplying
by i squared so if you have a look at
these two
yeah you see the flipping of signs if
you look at these two flipping signs
and you can do it with any like as long
as your gap is two right
hmm now the last thing i want you to
notice is
i call these numbers something specific
right i call them z1z2 there's the first
number the second number the third
and then the fourth if you were to
imagine because they aren't but if they
were
if you were to imagine these guys as
coordinates like it's pair of numbers
each time
coordinates on like a cartesian plane
where would these numbers go and what
relationship would there
be between them hume me
draw me a cartesian plane just
underneath where you got this
[Music]
and for the sake of the conclusion we're
about to draw right
get some decent scale on this if you
have a grid book then you're an
at an advantage i don't um and in the
hsc you won't
so i'm going to draw some quick little
indicators for me of
scale here and because of the numbers
we've got you can have to go up to five
everywhere so go ahead and put that so
you've got something consistent
and uh a ruler would be enormously
helpful
for this right i mean
one of the cheating things is it's
actually a lot easier to draw accurate
diagrams on a whiteboard because they're
huge
when you're doing it small you really
should if you want a straight line use a
ruler
so you can see i've got you know values
on my scale up to five
in all directions so so where would
this number here five comma two where
would that be
the first number it's going to be only
five comma two it's gonna be there
is that okay call that five comma two
first number over here where's the
second
number negative two five that's going to
be point two what's it gonna be
it's gonna be it's gonna be up here
right so i'm gonna go negative
two comma five so about there
ish negative two comma five right
uh and then i'm just gonna keep going
around right this first number's over
here
second number's over here third number
third number is down here isn't it
negative five negative two some over
here
negative five negative two and then
finally 2 comma negative 5 will be
here isn't that strange that the first
number it's in the first quadrant i just
defined that for you but if the first
one is in the first quadrant
then the second number ends up in the
second quadrant
and the third number's in the third
quadrant the fourth number's
in the fourth quadrant put one more
thing onto your diagram
just to help me out right from the
origin here if you imagine a line
extending upwards
right to my point over here and then
another line or an interval i should say
that goes from the origin to my next
point
and then another line over here another
interval another interval
right can you see and remember the z5
the z5 i asked you to calculate it ends
up back
over here right ends up five comma two
what is the operation that takes you
from
through these numbers the answer is i'm
multiplying by i but now if you think of
this
not as an arithmetic problem but as a
geometric
problem what operation gets you from the
first number to the second
it's 90 degrees i'm rotating
90's or pi on two radians right
and then what yeah i'm going
anti-clockwise as well because i started
here and i ended up in the second
quadrant
and then i do it again because i'm still
multiplying by i i rotate
again and then i rotate again
if you ever wondered why when we do
compass bearings right we say start from
true north
and then go clockwise right but then
for some reason when we moved into the
cartesian plane we then said
actually we want you to go
anti-clockwise don't worry about why
just we just want to mess with you and
make things as hard and arbitrary as
possible
why are we going the opposite direction
the answer is
because of this multiplication by i
it's rotating you around do you remember
when we had a look at those water
molecules right
the problem the reason why they were
invisible is because they were too small
do you remember that or too small why
could we never find why were these
complex numbers invisible to us well
if you want to think about the natural
numbers one two
three four five and so on right you can
imagine sort of progressing along
then we add the rational numbers you
sort of fill in the gaps right
all of those numbers are filled in
between them then when we said we add
the integers
we could say you can go off you know if
that's zero you can go off in the uh
the other direction as well and this is
what we call the number line
right but these complex numbers that we
are searching for
they're not anywhere on this number line
they're actually on a number
plane numbers are not one-dimensional
they can actually
exist in two dimensions
what you've drawn here you might have
noticed i very artfully did not actually
label
any of my axes this is not the cartesian
plane
that you're familiar with this is
actually what we call
the complex plane and in fact rather
than put these coordinates here right
this is not a pair of real numbers this
is actually just a single
complex number what that i does what
that imaginary unit does is it lifts you
off the number line or pushes you down
off of the number line
to a place that we didn't consider that
numbers
could be they were invisible because we
never
imagined that there could be things off
of this line
and so the complex plane is what we are
going to
explore what i got here the negative 2
plus 5i is what we're going to explore
in the coming weeks we have
a whole new universe to wait into i hope
you're excited to discover what awaits
you